why don't Jeremy Corbyn sports the right
about one thing
you can change British politics without
winning a general election I think a
Corbin leadership would profoundly
change both for labour and Tory parties
I think the overall result for labour
would be to mate labour unelectable
certainly in 2020 possibly for far
longer but I think perhaps the most
interesting thing is what the effect of
having the Tory party it's quite
striking how the more ideological
members of a cabinet I'm worried about
what a Corbin victory of being for the
Tories their fear is that Cameron
Altman's response to it would be to
attack to the centre hard in the hope of
picking up that kind of disillusion
people who maybe voted for labour last
time round but don't like the leftward
direction which Jeremy Corbyn is taking
the party Jeremy Corbyn leading the
Labour Party would mean that there was a
genuine choice between the political
parties if there wasn't already one of
the last elation which I think there was
it would obviously take labour to the
left it would mean that those who
support the Greens may feel that they
can support labour again and it would be
I suppose a test of whether socialism is
something that is due for a nationwide
revival or whether actually voters
aren't that keen on that well obviously
it's a min in a sense constitutionally
it's going to almost constitutionally
change Britain because the the Official
Opposition is to all intents and
purposes going to cease to exist so the
the Conservative government which is
seen the Liberal Democrats wiped out and
the Labour Party effectively cease to
exist an effective opposition is
essentially going to have a free run
it will mean one of two things for the
Labour Party it will either be a
disaster for the Labour Party meaning
the Labour Party or won't win the next
election may well not win the general
election after that or it could be the
end of the Labour Party as as we know it
it's conceivable that by electing a hard
left leader especially coming on the
back of of to election defeats electing
a hard left leader who does genuinely
take the labour party way off to the
left way or outside of the political
centre but at that point the British
people may say thank you very much but
that's enough now well it is very hard
to kill a British with one of the main
two British political parties you know
labour had a pretty good stab at it in
the 1980s and survived but I think the
core win thing suggests something else
which is believe party has not answered
the question of what is the point of the
Labour Party when there is no money left
to spend
and yes economic growth has come back
but I don't think we're going to be able
to return to a kind of era of the kind
of public spending that you saw when
Gordon Brown was at the Treasury and for
that reason I think until they becomes
up with a rationale for it in this era
of streets and public finances then it
is better to the party about a purpose I
think it's a watershed moment for the
Labour Party because there's been this
whole debate about whether Twitter and
Facebook and social media as the
left-wing
echo chamber but Corbyn has been elected
will have been elected on a wave of
grassroots support and normal people
will join the party and using social
media so I think if he does win people
who disregard social media will have to
come back and say well hang on a minute
the rump behind the new leader is all
very active on there for labour it's
very difficult it certainly means that
they will lose the next election it
might mean schism it might mean that
Tristan hunt and chicka I'm gonna decide
to sit off on their own in the same way
that the Gang of Four did in 1983 and
they might hold it together
but I don't think anybody in the labour
party knows the answer to this suffice
to say lots of soul-searching agony in
many many years in the wilderness